all right he's back with us he's the
host to see our TVs Levin TV the host of
life liberty Levin de Namur shows Sunday
night's 10:00 Eastern right here on Fox
I call him the great one Mark Levin so I
said at the beginning of the show we
have now witnessed the single worst 24
hours in the history of the mainstream
media which is saying a lot
because we know how corrupt they are
reaction well you know Sean what we've
learned about the media several of the
hosts and guess is we have a lot of
psychopaths out there that's for sure
while comparing the president's
conference with Putin to Pearl Harbor
9/11 crystal knocked the beginning of
the Holocaust calling him a traitor and
treasonous you know two weeks ago they
said he was running Japanese internment
camps and Nazi concentration camps this
is the pseudo media and now it comes to
Russia now the Liberals the media the
Democrats some Republicans very upset
about Russia you know they've had more
positions on Russia than stormy Daniels
as far as I'm concerned let me point out
some history this is very very important
John McCain god bless him and others
have said that what Trump did at that
press conference is the worst
interaction we've ever had with Russia
the worst diplomatic disaster ever I
want the American people forget about
the meet I want you to know something in
1945 at the Yalta Conference Franklin
Roosevelt sold out half of Europe to
Stalin he repeatedly praised Stalin
Franklin Roosevelt is the hero of the
Democrat Party he of Japanese internment
camps - in Yalta he gave up half of
Europe to the Soviet Union
in 1961 JFK met with Khrushchev JFK told
a friend of his that he was rolled over
that he came across week that it was
pretty disastrous his meeting with
Khrushchev and a few weeks later what do
they do the Soviets are shipping
missiles to Cuba and they're building a
wall in Berlin in 1975 Gerald Ford in
Helsinki with Brezhnev 35 other
countries
recognized recognize the territorial
sovereignty of the Soviet Union which
included the captive nations of Eastern
Europe in 1979 Jimmy Carter placed a big
wet kiss on Brezhnev's cheek in Vienna
all this hysteria about this press
conference the president said look I
could have said it better I should have
said this and they act like it's the
apocalypse it's not the left in this
country's defended the Rosenbergs they
defended out her hiss they defended Ted
Kennedy in 1983 and for when he was
colluding with the Kremlin to defeat
Reagan the left the Democrats the media
in this country opposed SDI the
Strategic Defense Initiative which had
as its purpose to defend us against
Russian nuclear missiles they called it
Star Wars to this day the left won't
fund it to this day the Democrat Party
opposes it they opposed his purging two
missiles to modernize medium-range
nuclear missiles which he eventually put
in Europe again to defeat the Soviet
Union so the left goes back and forth
the Democrats if in fact Donald Trump
returned to Putin after a two-hour
private meeting after setting up this
this summit and all of a sudden in
public turns to Putin and says look you
little bastard
we know you interfered in our election
they would be attacking Trump today the
way the Trump turned to the Germans and
NATO and said hey you're buying 70% of
your natural gas from the Russkies
you're funding their war machine and
then you asked us to subsidize you the
median the Democrats and the same people
went nuts but you know some more facts
Obama's President Obama did nothing
effective at all to stop the Russians
interference in our election he's the
one who ought to be under investigation
no pushback for the invasion of Georgia
no pushback for the annexation of Crimea
and Crimea no pushback for the invasion
of eastern Ukraine no pushback from
Russia's criminal shoot down a flight
mh17 teen he capitulated to Russia in
Syria he the unmet red lines his
betrayal of Poland and the Czech
Republic by his ceding to Russia's
demand to remove US missile defense
systems there he betrayed the Ukraine by
fusing to provide them with defensive
weapons now contrast that disaster that
utter appeasement to what Trump has done
in 18 months he's expanded sanctions on
Russian companies in apparatchiks he's
expanded and beefed up NATO he's had the
massive increase in US defense spending
no thanks to the Liberals restoring
missile defenses to Poland and the Czech
Republic returning heavy armored
divisions to Germany pre positioning
armed brigades in the Baltics ending
arms embargoes on Ukraine and Georgia
that Obama imposed on victims of Russian
aggression ending the ban of oil exports
to try and compete with the Russians
when it comes to their oil and I could
go on and on and on on this these are
these are notes how you typed out on
this so all this hysteria the fact of
the matter is Trump hasn't done a thing
to harm America with respect to Russia
and Obama did nothing to protect America
when he came to Russia the same attitude
Obama had when he came to the Chinese in
the South China Sea building their phony
Islands the North Koreans as they're
building their nukes the Iranians he
gave them a hundred and fifty billion
dollars and a wet kiss on the lips
so the attacks on Trump this overwrought
historical insane attack by the media
the Democrats some in the Republican
Party and some phony conservatives so I
ask you this the question of president
just don't go nuts no they can't help
themselves because their narrative would
look you can't see this without seeing
it through the prism of 2018 it's now
because they can't run on the economy
anymore they're telling Maxine and
others to be quiet about impeaching they
want open borders they want Obamacare
they want their crumbs back and now
they're kind of desperate because the
Muller investigation hasn't brought them
what they wanted in 18 months but we
have had Russia collusion and as much as
Russian lies were paid for and
disseminated to the American people
about Donald Trump in a presidential
election and they were use to get a
warrant in a presidential election
against the Trump campaign that seems to
me like like a pretty important factor
that they don't report on mark
- two entities interfered in our
election the Russians and the Obama
administration the Democrats defend the
Obama administration and all of a sudden
they don't like the Russians so they've
been Cal telling to City 1917 now you
know what that's why we call you the
great one don't we will see mark on
Sunday Night Life Liberty Levin 10:00
p.m.
number one show on cable